على الاراضي الاوكرانيه تتواصل حرب
الاستنزاف الجانب الروسي تمكن اخيرا من
تحقيق مكاسب اضافيه والاوكرانيه الذي
يتحضر لهجوم مضاد كثر الحديث عنها هجوم
سيشمل مواقع استراتيجيه عديده ابرزها
منشاه زابوريجيا النوويه التي تشهد هدوءا
نسبيا والهدف سيكون حسم المعركه وتفادي
خساره يمكن ان تكون مصحوبه هذه المره
بكارثه نوويه محتمله تقرير صادر عن صحيفه
واشنطن بوست كشف عن استعداد المدير العام
للوكاله الدوليه رفيال الدروسى لطرح خطه
امميه لمجلس الامن الدولي هدفها حمايه
محطه زابوريج النوويه وتجنب كارثه محتمله
هذه الخطه التي سيقدمها بروسي لمجلس الامن
اواخر الشهر الجاري ستكون مرهونه بموافقه
غال الاعضاء لتمريرها فهي ترتكز على خمسه
محاور رئيسيه هي حظر نشر معدات عسكريه
ثقيله وافراد عسكريين في المحطه وحظروا
اطلاق النار منها وفي اتجاه المحطه بما في
ذلك حظر مهاجمه العاملين في الموقع يضاف
الى ذلك حمايه جميع انظمه الامن والسلامه
في المكان وحمايه جميع خطوط الطاقه
الخارجيه ورصد الامتثال للمبادئ المذكوره
وتاتي خطه جروسي الذي فشل في وقت سابق في
اقناع الجانب الاوكراني والروسي بانشاء
محطه امنه حول محيط المحطه باكملها في وقت
بدات خريطه المعارك في اوكرانيا تتغير
بعدما فرض فصل الشتاء اسلوبه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات